on va passer au top 5 people les cherry
et en ce moment avec le confinement de
nombreuses célébrités se met à fond sur
les réseaux pour faire kiffer leurs fans
et on a deux d'entre elles qui ont
complètement réussi en reformant un duo
mythique c'est franck dubosc et elie
semoun puisque c'est le retour des
bandes annonces et des petites annonces
pas des bandes-annonces mercedes et
jeanine regarder sans doute y passe un
ras-le-bol
si après les annonces du prolongement du
confinement on pouvait avoir peur que le
temps soit l'ont heureusement certains
ont décidé de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
nous divertir c'est le cas de franck
dubosc et elie semoun qui sont de retour
dans leur duo mythique
alors qu'il ya quelques jours le duo
d'humoristes avait fait son grand retour
à titre exceptionnel dans un sketch
tournée chacun depuis leur cuisine
nîmois foire qui se souvient de cette
épidémie 2001 ici enfin rappelle toi et
nous avait confiné pendant deux ans
voilà que le succès semble leur avoir
donné envie de continuer et cette fois
ci c'est carrément dans la peau de leurs
personnages cultes mercedes et jeanine
que les deux comédiens ont tapé reprêter
durant des années dans les petites
annonces d'elie qu'ils ont décidé de
donner leur vision du confinement qu'on
n'a pas quant à la con finalement il me
passerais courir note spéciale pour le
maquillage maison autre sketch autre
ambiance avec cette discussion de deux
amis autour d'une partie d'échecs échec
et masques échec et marches qui le
masque
des sketches et un succès qui on
l'espère donneront hodiall envie de se
lancer dans un huitième volet des
petites annonces version 2009 à londres
espère et ça fait du bien c'est vrai
qu'ils sont très très drôle les deux les
chéris vous savez quand je m'engage en
plus de personnes qui rêvent de 10
confinement et de revoir aussi les
matches de ligue 1 des matches de foot
et aujourd'hui on apprend dans l'équipe
que la ligue 1 donc le championnat de
france de foot pourrait reprendre en
juin mais il ya un gros problème c'est
que certains joueurs sont rentrés dans
leur pays d'origine et pourrait se
retrouver bloqués à l'étranger
c'est notamment le cas de la star neymar
regarde très vite après la montée de
l'épidémie de coronavirus en france et
le confinement imposée par le président
de la république le 16 mars de nombreux
joueurs de football avait fait le choix
de rentrer dans leur pays d'origine
à l'instar de neymar mais voilà si ce
choix de se rapprocher de leur famille
pouvait se comprendre dans un premier
temps la situation semble aujourd'hui se
compliquer car si l'épidémie a d'abord
touché l'europe elle se répand
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier y
compris au brésil où plusieurs joueurs
du psg comme neymar ou thiago silva
séjourne aujourd'hui mitchell baker est
quant à lui rentré au pays bas sauf que
voilà si en france le dès confinement
pourrait progressivement se dérouler à
partir du 11 mai prochain avec la
fermeture des frontières européennes et
l'épidémie qui se développe en amérique
du sud pas sûr que ces stars pourront
rentrer à temps pour disputer les
premiers matches de ligue 1 ou de la
champion's league et même s'ils avaient
la possibilité de rentrer pour éviter
tout risque les joueurs seraient
probablement placé à l'isolément pour
une période de 14 jours minimum comme il
est coutume de faire partout dans le
monde
une situation qui inquiète grandement
les instances du psg qui pourrait être
gravement handicapé par ses absences si
une reprise des matches même à huis clos
se dérouler dans les semaines à venir
alors à mon rêve mon raymond sa touche
de cette terre enceinte ça ça parait ça
paraît bizarre quand même de reprendre
mi juin sachant qu'il va pas une grosse
préparation des joueurs parce que tu
n'es pas repartir sur un terrain comme
ça du jour au lendemain à huis clos pas
à huis clos ce que les gens ont droit de
venir en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que la liga le met une pression sur le
club pour pouvoir toucher son argent des
diffuseurs parce que les diffuseurs ne
veulent pas payer tant qu'il n'y a pas
de matches qui sont diffusées donc on
sait qu'il ya une pression de ce côté là
déjà
mais cinq mois ça me paraît bizarre mi
juin rené malleville rené web et moi
j'ai été durant de cheveux ça nous
dérange pas plus que ça et sur 3 puis on
n'a pas beaucoup de points de retard sur
paris tenir mais si on peut être premier
il ya des choses qui sont importantes
c'est le marseillais parents et on a le
droit on a le droit de rigoler un peu la
raison mort d ilan immense star qui
vient de pousser un énorme coup de
gueule contre ses propres fans c'est le
numéro trois du top 5 by paul c'est
rihanna elle s'est lâchée contre lui
demander pour la 100e fois quand est ce
qu'elle est enfin sortir son album
certes ils illustrent tous les fans de
rihanna attendent la sortie de ce
neuvième album mais la chanteuse elle
n'en peut plus qu'on la harcèle avec
cette question elle a pété un câble
rihanna elle a dit nico mook regarde
qu'elle il faut croire que même
lorsqu'on a des millions et une maison
avec jardin le confinement n'est pas
forcément une chose facile c'est dans
tous les cas ce que le pétage de plomb
de rihanna peut laisser supposer un
pétage de plomb qui s'est déroulé en
direct sur internet
alors que la star avait décidé elle
aussi de se lancer dans une séance de
questions réponses avec ses fans et ceux
qui a fait visiblement vrillé la star
c'est une énième relance sur la date de
sortie de son album
il faut dire qu'entre les fans et
rihanna cette histoire d'albums commence
à durer elle n'a pas sorti d'album solo
depuis 2016 un album que les fans
attendent toujours une question donc
légitime de la part des internautes sauf
que voilà la chanteuse n'en peut plus de
cette question elle a fait savoir
bande de connards
si l'un d'entre vous me demande encore
une fois quand il va sortir alors que
j'essaye de sauver le monde
contrairement à tous nos présidents je
tire à vue une sortie en rap qui a
visiblement laissé sans voix de nombreux
internautes qui ne comprennent pas la
réaction de la star une chose est sûre
la prochaine fois ils y réfléchiront à
deux fois avant de pousser riri dans ses
retranchements
allait elle est chaude l'ariana alors
vous allez réagir dans un instant
jean-michel l'air on aura le top-20
coupe également et vous verrez qu'il est
le numéro 1 des pipoles sachez le bon
c'est lady gaga lady gaga qui s'est
engagée et qui a lancé un appel à notre
président on vous dira pourquoi lady
gaga qui a mis un tweet sur notre
président emmanuel macron les cherry on
est dans le top 5 people on vient de
voir rihanna qui a poussé un coup de
gueule et y en a un autre qui a poussé
un coup de gueule c'est pire jean
salençon vous savez d'affaires conclut
lui s'est lâché contre meghan markle et
le prince harry
à cause de la divulgation du prix de la
maison que le couple vient d'acheter à
malibu regardez et dites nous ce que
vous en pensez après pire jean chalencon
que de nombreux téléspectateurs ont
découvert grâce à l'émission à faire
conclut de sophie davant sur france 2
est un véritable personnage qui n'hésite
pas à dire ce qu'il pense quand il a
quelque chose sur le coeur ils nouvelle
fois ce fan de napoléon la jouer franc
jeu
cette fois ci ce sont mes gars nehari
qui en ont pris pour leur grade sur les
réseaux en réaction et news du compte
officiel de la radio rtl
annonçant l'installation du couple en
californie et l'acquisition d'une
nouvelle maison à la lecture de cette
information le sens du collectionneur
n'a fait qu'un tour et il n'a pas pu
s'empêcher de répondre de façon pour le
moins virulente
cette famille est indécente des smicards
sans leur famille le monde perd pied et
e
bref qu'on leur coupe la tête une sortie
d'une violence rare qui a même choqué
plusieurs de ses followers qui n'ont pas
compris pourquoi s'en prendre
particulièrement à ce couple
voilà donc pierre-jean il s'est énervé
bon comme d'habitude on aimait ce que tu
es rené tu t'en fous de mégane et arrive
bien en chalencon ça te sa tante une
sans faire bouger l'autre j'en étais sûr
les battait un petit peu capter petit à
petit un petit peu comme nous
franchement mégane et harry non non on
n'en peut plus en plus en revanche lady
gaga elle est numéro 1 du top 5
aujourd'hui people puisque lady gaga
s'engage et lance un appel à une
manuelle mâcon s'est complètement ouf
moi quand j'ai vu ce tweet je croyais
que c'était un faux lady gaga a envoyé
un message à emmanuel macron en décompte
la chance ces frais de recevoir un
message de lady gaga
franchement pourquoi elle n'a pas écrit
un mois rien moi j'ai eu juste les
digues ont cédé
décidément cette période de pandémie
permet aux couples macron de se faire
plein de nouveaux amis après l'appel de
brigitte à nabila pour la remercier de
son don c'est aujourd'hui la star lady
gaga qui lance un appel à emmanuel
macron pour lui demander de l'aide
il faut dire que l'interprète de poker
face est particulièrement active dans la
mobilisation autour du coc vite 19 grâce
à ses contacts et à sa force médiatique
la star a réussi en quelques jours a
levé pas moins de 35 millions de dollars
pour venir en aide à l'om s est tenté
par tous les moyens de lutter le plus
efficacement possible contre la
propagation du coronavirus c'est donc
forte de cette action spectaculaire que
la chanteuse a décidé d'interpeller le
président de la république pour lui
demander de se mobiliser dans cette
action président emmanuel macron on a
besoin de votre soutien dans la lutte
mondiale contre le colis de 19 nous
sommes en tant que citoyen du monde tous
dans le même bateau un message dans
l'air pour demander au président des
gestes forts à destination de tous les
pays pour lutter collectivement dans cet
effort à l'heure actuelle malgré 33 me
like et des milliers d'euros tweet
emmanuel macron n'a pas réagi
officiellement à ce message
et il n'a pas encore réagi le président
à l'appel d'olivier gaga c'est fou ça
mathieu c'est ouf quand même alors moi
j'adore les gens qui parlent gens qui
font s'est elle aussi j'en sais pas si
vous le savez que chaque est à
l'initiative d'un concert qui s'appelle
one world to gather in the world et
c'est toutes les stars qui vont céline
dion les plus grandes stars katy perry
qui vont chanter depuis chez eux ça va
être leur concert mondial
et voilà c'est fait avec l' oms et voilà
franchement on a rarement vu une star à
ce point s'impliquent et récolté autant
de millions qu'elle en ce moment et
d'ailleurs j'ai envie de dire pardon oui
madonna quand elle n'est pas dans sa
baignoire pendant pour qu'on n'entend
pas la plus grande mano demande une star
planétaire qu'est ce qu'elle fout en
prenant à part prendre des bains